alors il y a il y a un article qui pose
problème c'est un article de Paris Match
avec la une euh en une Muriel Robin
Muriel Robin donc qui est la plus proche
le père Palmade dans la tête des gens et
et c'est vrai qu'on a et ils ont fait la
Une Muriel Robin le 4 consciences et
Muriel Robin quelques heures après la
publication de cette une elle a réagi
sur Twitter en affirmant qu'elle n'a
jamais donné son accord pour qu'une
telle une et un tel article soit publié
bonjour il est important pour moi de
vous informer que la couverture de Paris
Match ainsi que l'article à l'intérieur
du journal ont été fait sans me
concerter donc sans mon accord Muriel
c'est vrai que Muriel elle a parce que
quand on voit à la couverture on est
persuadé qu'on Muriel Robin a accordé
une interview et qu'on va avoir les
premiers première réaction de Muriel
Robin suite à à ce drame mais pas du
tout hein Myriam non pas du tout elle a
pas elle a pas donné son accord en même
temps dans son tweet elle dit pas que ce
que dit Paris Match est faux
ça veut dire ce qu'elle dit c'est ce
qu'elle dit en fait en bas c'est ce
qu'elle veut dire puisqu'elle dit j'ai
pas participé voilà donc on était fait
sans me concerter donc sans me concerter
ça veut dire que voilà après c'est pas
c'est pas si on est ils disent quoi dans
cet article alors dans cet article donc
ils reviennent effectivement sur la
l'amitié longue la longue amitié entre
Pierre Palmade et Muriel Roma qui se
connaissent depuis 30 ans elle le
considérait comme son fils spirituel etc
ils ont énormément travaillé ensemble et
du coup par image revient sur les
premières heures de l'accident à partir
donc du 10 février au soir ou Muriel
Robin alors qu'elle était aux Victoires
de la musique s'est rendu à l'hôpital du
Kremlin-Bicêtre pour aller voir son ami
en service de réanimation elle y est
allée avec avec sa femme Anne Le Nen et
puis la par image raconte comment au fil
des jours au bout de trois jours Muriel
Robin a décidé de complètement
se déconnecter de Pierre Palmade et de
ne plus aller le voir à l'hôpital il
raconte aussi que la croisée en fait
donc c'est quoi l'histoire après tu peux
développer maintenant
tu me poses des questions
en gros le dimanche elle a rencontré
dans les couloirs de l'hôpital les
familles des victimes et là elle a eu un
gros quatre consciences elle s'est même
elle-même son petit coupable en disant
que elle aurait pu peut-être en faire
davantage et c'est pas faux d'avoir
essayé de de de soigner Pierre Palmade
et quand elle a vu ses victimes là ça a
été le couper et elle n'a pas elle n'a
pas pu pardonner à Pierre Palmade et
elle lui a même écrit une lettre en lui
disant que tout était de sa faute et que
et que elle ne pouvait pas et qu'elle ne
pouvait pas lui pardonner ce ce cet
épisode que c'était trop dur pour elle
ensuite elle a pris donc la décision de
ne plus retourner le voir à l'hôpital
elle a même décidé ça je vous en avais
déjà parlé de prendre le large et de
partir quelques temps se reposer dans le
sud de la France à la frontière de
l'Espagne avec avec sa femme elle s'est
totalement désolidarisée de Pierre
Palmade
j'ai les infos elle est choquée par ce
qui s'est passé forcément
pour l'instant comme on dit c'est c'est
elle veut pas réagir comme tous ses
proches parce qu'elle se dit la décence
pour les victimes c'est de c'est de
c'est de ne pas réagir elle est énervée
par cette une je suppose que oui elle
était très énervée c'est normal ça c'est
c'est une réalité mais elle est aussi
très accablée par cet épisode comme ça
sont les accords des personnes
concernées
là aucunement pour eux voilà c'est une
enquête n'est pas formulée que c'est une
interview il y a pas marqué interview
exclusive il y a pas de propos entre
guillemets ils ont droit ils ont ces
infos là qui pour d'ailleurs j'avais les
mêmes infos que ce qu'ils disent n'est
pas faux donc elle va leur faire un
procès de toute façon pas vraiment parce
qu'il y a pas il y a pas vraiment de
dire il y a pas de diffamation
de l'image la première page
non plus d'atteinte à la vie privée
après
une lettre à l'hôpital oui il raconte
donc la lettre qu'elle lui a écrit tout
ce que je vous disais tout à l'heure où
elle lui dit clairement ta faute et
voilà je ne peux pas te pardonner elle
se sent mais alors ils disent plein de
trucs ils disent que quand elle a eu
connaissance des résultats des examens
toxicologiques son ami elle s'est dit
écoeurée
ils disent que voilà comme vous dites
qu'il y a des quitté Paris loin de cette
agitation et il y a eu aussi l'histoire
de la paix de pornographie aussi qu'il a
qu'il aille branlé même si par la suite
l'enquête a révélé que il n'y avait que
on n'avait pas retrouvé de de d'images
de ce type dans dans les disques durs de
Pierre Palmade mais tout ça a fait que
bah elle a décidé de de silence total et
de se décider oui je dis pas que c'est
pas normal pour vous c'est normal elle
s'est fait beaucoup critiquer pour ça et
au contraire je pense que c'est la
décence de de garder le silence dans un
moment comme ça ça veut pas dire qu'elle
ne l'aime pas qu'elle n'est pas une amie
mais il y a un moment par rapport à la
famille décimée il fallait un peu de
l'essence et d'ailleurs c'est normal oui
c'est normal mais d'ailleurs elle prend
régulièrement quand même des des
nouvelles de son état de santé quand il
s'est fait opérer mardi
quel est son état de santé alors là ça
va mieux les retourner au
Kremlin-Bicêtre il a été donc opéré
c'est un AVC sérieux il a des séquelles
ou pas du tout ah il a pas vraiment de
séquelles pour l'instant ils lui ont
fait une petite opération chirurgicale
et là il a pu être transféré au
Kremlin-Bicêtre c'est tout la plaidoirie
de son avocat qui dit que il est encore
à moins de riz la juge d'instruction
aussi et ça va dans le sens d'une
expertise médicale qui a eu lieu qui
laisse à penser que avant le 15 mars
avant la mi-mars il est impossible de le
réincarrer et ses avocats s'appuient
là-dessus parce qu'il est trop faible il
est pas en bon état etc après quand il
dit jusqu'à la mi-mars ça veut dire que
pour eux dans quelques jours il pourrait
y avoir un nouvel examen de son permis
mars c'est là oui mais là la décision ce
matin mardi donc on dirait que tu nous
as dit pour pessarprono
elle est vraiment traumatisée en plus le
timing il est déplorable parce qu'elle
est à l'affiche d'un film là qui va
sortir qui raconte l'histoire d'un
enfant qui se fait faucher dans un
accident de la route elle a même pas été
capable de vous assister à
l'avant-première tellement les sous le
choc
c'est vraiment terrible elle pourrait
c'est une victime collatérale qui n'a
rien à voir dans l'affaire et moi Muriel
franchement je porte tout mon soutien
parce que voilà elle sait que je l'aime
beaucoup Muriel et je sais pas comment
nous on aurait réagi dans un dans un cas
comme celui-là et c'est vrai que c'est
une situation très très compliqué
Jean-Marie oui ben moi j'avais
maintenant un peu pressé
parce que vous étiez un peu fâché
c'était perdu de vue depuis très depuis
très longtemps mais muriel a été
toujours comme ça avec pire c'est
différent pour elle c'est très très
pénible évidemment bien sûr pour Muriel
moi je ne voudrais pas être à sa place
je suis comme elle moi j'ai du mal à
dormir avec cette histoire et je suis
impuissant comme elle elle est donc on
ne peut rien faire et
plutôt rien dire que de dire quelque
chose sans risquer de dire une connerie
c'est sûr Benjamin vous avez des news
non mais je sais un peu par mon meilleur
ami qui est très proche de deux pierres
ils sont en fait il y a beaucoup de
colère parce qu'ils sont effectivement
en colère contre leur ami parce que ils
ont tout essayé pour lui c'est ça qui
est affreux ils ont vraiment essayé de
de ils ont entendu il y a 2 ans à son
anniversaire avec ses 4 meilleurs potes
en disant voilà on vient te dire pour
que tu arrêtes tes conneries et ce qui
les rend fou c'est qu'en fait il l'a
jamais rien écouté alors c'est ils sont
terrassés par les parcs qui est arrivé
aux victimes ils sont terrassés par leur
impuissance et c'est tout ça il y a
assez mélangé et c'est pour ça qu'il
préfère se taire mais c'est vrai que
c'est et le cas de conscience qu'on
prend l'arc de Paris Match dans le cas
de conscience ils sont en colère en fait
contre leur âme elle n'a pas été là pour
première de son film elle s'est rendue
mais elle a pas été capable d'assister
au film c'est d'accord elle s'est rendu
à l'avant-première mais elle a pas pu
visionner le film parce que ça raconte
l'histoire d'un enfant qui se fait
vraiment faucher dans un accident de la
route et ça sort là c'est un film qui va
sortir de cet enfant elle a juste été
elle a pour pour honorer quand même
l'équipe elle a été voir elle a été au
pot à formel qu'ils ont fait ensuite
mais elle a pas pu il a pas pu regarder
le film